the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hi as I was standing here wondering how
to begin today's lesson an old story
came to mind of the professor who passed
out an examination to his class and one
of the students said professor this is
the same test you gave us last week and
the professor said I know but this time
I changed the answers and I was thinking
of this in terms of the fact that much
of the new mathematics is essentially
the old mathematics with some of the
answers changed one of the topics that
we used to belittle in the traditional
curriculum because it was too easy was
the topic called linear equations and it
turns out that in the study of several
variables in particular but it was
already present in calculus of a single
variable we very strongly used the
concept of linearity I could have called
today's lesson something old something
new meaning that the old topic that we
were going to revisit would be that of
linear functions and the new topic would
be how it manifests into the modern
curriculum in the sense that one
introduces a subject called linear
algebra or matrix algebra as a standard
portion of a modern calculus course
whereas in the traditional calculus
courses essentially nothing was ever
said about matrix algebra or linearity
instead I picked a more conservative
title for today's lesson I simply call
it linearity revisited and as I say it
goes back to when we were in junior high
school or high school when we were
taught that linear functions were very
nice for example given the equation y
equals MX plus B the linear equation
meaning what it graphs as a straight
line but that the two variables are
related linearly in other words Y is a
constant multiple of X plus a constant
we were told solve for X in terms of Y
and what we found was that if y equals
MX plus B this was true if and only if X
was equal to Y minus B over m in other
words what we showed was given a value
of x there correspond at a value of y
and conversely given a value for
why they correspond to their unique
value for X and to put this into the
language of functions what we were
saying was that if f of X equals MX plus
B then F inverse exists in other words
what we're saying is that no two
different X values can give you the same
y value if the function has the form y
equals MX plus B and just about the time
that we were learning to enjoy this kind
of an equation our dream world was
shattered and we were told it's too bad
but most functions aren't linear we were
given things like y equals x to the
seventh plus X to the fifth and we found
that we couldn't solve for X very
conveniently in terms of Y and that's
what began our intermediate algebra in
advanced algebra courses in other words
the fact that most functions are
nonlinear now an interesting thing
occurred though let me just emphasize
this and this is the key point in terms
of calculus we discovered and here's a
key would coming up most functions are
locally lilia and that sounds a little
bit like a tongue twister but actually
back in the first part of our course
when we talked about Delta Y sub 10 in
other words the change in Y to the
tangent line notice what we were saying
we were saying that the study f of X
near F equals a we saw that F of a plus
Delta X minus F of a was equal to F
prime of a times Delta X plus K Delta X
where the limit of K as Delta X went to
zero was zero itself provided of course
that F was differentiable at x equals a
otherwise you couldn't write down F
prime of a here the interesting point is
this but if you look just at this term
over here this is a this expresses Delta
F as a linear function of Delta X the
part that makes this thing nonlinear is
the term called K Delta X but that's the
term that's going to 0 as a second-order
infinitesimally
so what we're really saying is this that
provided that F is differentiable at X
equal
they in other words locally we mean this
year x equals a we can say that Delta F
is approximately F prime of a times
Delta X that's what we call Delta F sub
10 recall and the reason what we mean by
approximately here is that that error K
Delta X goes to zero very very rapidly
as Delta X goes to zero and what we mean
by locally is this
suppose F prime exists also at x equals
B we can again compute Delta F near x
equals B now Delta F is equal to what
approximately F prime of B times Delta X
plus that error term which goes to zero
very rapidly we again call this thing
here Delta F 10 but the thing to keep in
mind is is that since F prime of a need
not equal F prime of B Delta F 10 is
different at a and at B in other words
even though it's always true where F is
differentiable that we can say that
Delta F is approximately Delta F 10 the
value of Delta F 10 depends on the value
of x that we're near and that's what we
mean by saying that approximating Delta
F by Delta F 10 is a local property now
I think that sometimes by putting these
things into words it sounds harder than
it really is so I think what might be
nice is if we just look at a specific
illustration a problem which I
deliberately picked to be as simple a
nonlinear example as I can think of let
me come back to our old friend the
function f of X equals x squared which
as I say is about as simple a nonlinear
function as we can get into now we know
that f of X equals x squared plots as
the curve y equals x squared the
parabola let's take a couple of points
on this parabola let's say the point 1
comma 1 and the point 2 comma 4 draw in
the tangent lines to the curves at these
two poetic to the curve at these two
points and we know what that the
equation of the tangent line to the
curve at 1 1 is
why minus one over X minus one equals
the slope since Y is equal to x-squared
the slope is 2 X when X is 1 the slope
is 2 so the equation of this tangent
line is given by y minus 1 over X minus
1 equals 2 at the point corresponding to
x equals 2 to X is 4 so the equation of
a tangent line here is y minus 4 over X
minus 2 equals 4 so now I've induced 3
functions that I can talk about my
original function f of X is x squared
this straight line is the linear
function just solving for Y in terms of
X G of x equals 4x minus 4 and this
straight line corresponds to the
function H of x equals 2x minus 1 now
the interesting point of course is that
these two functions here are linear they
are completely different functions
noticed not only pictorially are they
different
but algebraically their slopes are
different and their y-intercepts are
different and back in our course in part
1 we talked about things geometrically
saying look at near the point of
tangency the tangent line serves as a
good approximation to the curve itself
what were we really saying then what we
were saying was that near the point of
tangency G of X say which was a linear
function could replace f of X which was
a nonlinear function of course when we
move too far away from a given point
then when we said that f of X still had
a linear approximation we had to pick a
different linear function by the way
again because we were dealing with one
independent variable and one dependent
variable it was very easy to invent the
concept of a graph as we shall show in a
little while the concept of linearity
extends to several variables but you
can't draw the graph as nicely so let me
now revisit the same result here only
without reference to the graph what
we're saying is by the way notice that
our function is mapping the real number
line into the real number line in other
words instead of putting x and y it
to each other let's put X&Y horizontally
parallel to one another
and what we're saying is that F for
example maps the interval from zero to
two onto the interval from zero to four
now what does H do remember H is the
function 2x minus 1 H maps the interval
from zero to two onto the interval from
minus one to three and you see this is
all this diagram means f maps 0 into 0
it maps 1 into 1 it Maps 2 into it maps
2 into 4 etc in other words f is the
function which squares the input to
yield the output and correspondingly H
maps 0 into minus 1 it maps 1 into 1 and
it maps 2 into 3 etc now the interesting
point is is that F and H are very
different in fact the only time F and H
have the same output is when H is when x
equals 1 which of course we knew from
before because how was H of X
constructed H of X was constructed to be
the line tangent to the parabola y
equals x squared at the point x equals 1
y equals 1 so that's should be no great
surprise but if we didn't know that
notice that algebraically we could
equate f of X to H of X conclude
therefore that that means x squared must
equal to X minus 1
we then transpose and get that X plus X
minus 1 squared must be 0
whence X must equal 1 and what we have
is that near x equals 1 x squared
behaves like and I put this in quotation
marks because that's the hardest part of
the course that's going to follow is
just what you mean by behaves like but x
squared behaves like 2x minus 1 and what
we mean by that is this at least in
terms of a picture if I pick a small
interval surrounding x equals 1 on the x
axis and a small interval like a thick
dot surrounding y equals 1 on the y axis
here then as a mapping from this domain
in
to this range I can essentially not
distinguish F from H in other words the
error is so small but as the thickness
of the interval the size of the interval
shrinks the error goes to zero even
faster and therefore if I stay close
enough locally to the point in question
if I stay close enough to this point I
cannot tell the difference between the
nonlinear function and the linear
function but what I have to be careful
about is this that what whereas x
squared can be replaced by 2x minus 1
near x equals 1 near x equals 2 x
squared can be replaced again by a
linear function namely 4x minus 4 but 4x
minus 4 is not approximately the same as
2x minus 1 no matter where you look you
might say well look at don't these two
straight lines intersect at a particular
point the answer is yes they do but even
at the point that they intersect there
is no neighborhood in which these lines
can serve as approximations for one
another in other words those are two
straight lines that intersect at a
constant angle and as soon as you leave
the point of intersection there is a
significant error meaning an arrow which
does not go to 0 more rapidly than the
change in X in other words you don't
have that higher or the infinitesimal
over here at any rate leaving this to
the exercises and the supplementary
notes for you to get more out of in
summary let's just say this if f is
continuously differentiable at x equals
a then locally meaning near x equals a a
f behaves linearly in other words f of X
is approximately f of a plus F prime of
a times the quantity X minus a and you
see once X is chosen to be a this is a
number this is a number Delta X here is
the only variable on the right hand side
so what we're saying is that f of X is a
what linear function of Delta X and the
more interesting point is since this is
all review so I say what I mean by more
interesting point is what that we don't
have to just review this way we did this
simply to refresh your memories as to
how linearity was playing a big role
in calculus of a single variable now
what we're going to do is extend the
result to several variables and so let
me just say that at the outset that this
concept does extend to n variables but N
equals two yields a particularly good
geometric insight for example let's
suppose I look at two equations and two
unknowns well actually I'll use U and V
and so that let those be variables also
we can think of this as a function in
other words I have U of X Y is x squared
minus y squared whereas V of XY is 2xy
notice that these are not linear because
here we have things appearing to second
part your squares and here we have what
the variable is multiplying one another
these are not linear equations but the
beautiful point is if you want look at
it this way is even without a picture I
can think of this as a mapping which
maps two dimensional space into two
dimensional space and how does this
mapping take place it Maps the point or
the pair or the to topple whichever way
you want to say it X comma Y into the to
topple u comma V where u is x squared
minus y squared and Z is 2xy in other
words F bar and notice I put the bar
underneath simply to indicate that e to
is a vector space and we have a function
that's mapping what a vector into a
vector so I indicate that F is a vector
function here it maps a vector into a
vector and how does the mapping take
place it Maps the to topple X comma Y
into the to topple x squared minus y
squared comma 2xy
you.they now the thing is that as long
as we only have N equals 2 we can still
draw a picture but not a picture as nice
as what existed when n was equal to 1
see pictorially f bar maps the XY plane
into what we can call the UV plane but
notice that since the domain of f bar
has two degrees of freedom a two
dimensional vector space notice that the
domain of f bar is the entire XY plane
whereas the range of f bar is the entire
uv-plane in other words i can now view f
bar as a mapping which carries points in
the XY plane into points in the UV plane
and this will be exploited more later in
the course
but the idea is this let's take a look
for the time being let's see what f bar
does to the point 2 comma 1 remember u
is x squared minus y squared so the
point 2 comma 1 U becomes what 2 squared
minus 1 squared which is 3 on the other
hand 2 XY is 2 times 2 times 1 which is
4 so f bar can be viewed as mapping the
point 2 comma 1 into the point 3 comma 4
now you recall that calculus isn't
interested in what's happening at a
particular point
it's interested in what's happening in
the neighborhood of a particular point
so the major question is how does f bar
behave near the point 2 comma 1 in other
words one is F power of 2 plus Delta X
comma 1 plus Delta Y when Delta X and
Delta Y are quite small that's the
question that we're raising over here in
other words what we're saying is look at
we know that 2 comma 1 maps into 3 comma
4 we also know or we'd like to believe
that a point near 2 comma 1 maps into a
point near 3 comma 4 well if we call
this point 2 plus Delta X comma 1 plus
Delta Y then the corresponding image
over here should be 3 plus Delta u comma
4 plus Delta V in other words what we
can say is that whatever the image of 2
plus Delta X comma 1 plus Delta Y is it
has to form 3 plus Delta u comma 4 plus
Delta V and all we have to do is find
out that U and Delta V in other words
this is the pictorial idea of what's
happening now the point is that Delta U
and Delta V are very difficult to find
after all you and V are nonlinear
functions to invert them is either
difficult or downright impossible one of
the other in many cases the thing that's
easy to find is Delta u tan and Delta V
tan
remember Delta u tan was the partial of
Europe respect to x times Delta X plus
the partial of U with respect to Y times
Delta Y since u is equal to x squared
minus y squared that means Delta u tan
is 2 X Delta X minus two Y Delta Y we're
interested in this at the point 2 comma
1 letting X be 2 and y be 1 we see that
Delta u tan is 4 Delta X minus 2 Delta Y
similarly since V is equal to 2xy the
partial of V with respect to X is 2 y
the partial of V with respect to Y is 2x
therefore Delta V sub tan is 2 Y Delta X
plus 2 X Delta Y since we're evaluating
this at x equals 2 y equals 1 we see
that Delta V tan is 2 Delta X plus 4
Delta Y now here's the key point
this is always Delta u 10 this is always
Delta V 10 well the local thing comes in
is that we know that because U and V are
continuously differentiable functions of
x and y that near near the point 2 comma
1 we can replace Delta u by Delta u sub
10 Delta V by Delta V sub 10 and we wind
up with what Delta U was approximately
for Delta X minus 2 Delta Y Delta V is
approximately 2 Delta X plus 4 Delta Y
but the key point now is that this is a
system of linear equations you see Delta
U is a linear combination of Delta X and
Delta Y and Delta V is also a linear
combination of Delta X and Delta Y in
other words as long as u and V are
continuously differentiable functions of
Delta of X and y we can approximate
locally Delta U and Delta V by linear
approximations in other words notice how
linear systems come into play now I've
been emphasizing the case N equals 2
just so we could draw a picture notice
that no matter how many variables we
have well in fact let me just summarize
this in terms of X and Y first and then
we'll sum generalize it to end variable
in a minute the key point for two
variables and what happens for two
variables happens for any number but as
we've often done in this course we
emphasize the two variable case because
we can still visualize the picture even
though the graph idea is hard to see
because we're mapping two dimensions
into two dimensions but at least as I
say the domain and the range are easy to
see separately but if you is a
continuously differentiable function of
x and y near the point x0 y0 then delta
u is exactly the partial of U with
respect to X times Delta X plus the
partial of U with respect to Y times
Delta Y plus an error term k1 Delta X
plus k2 Delta Y where k1 and k2 go to 0
as Delta X and Delta Y go to zero in
other words if we just look at this part
alone Delta U is linear up to this as a
correction term in other words the
non-linearity part of Delta U is going
to 0 as a second-order infinitesimal and
the reason I keep harping on this point
is that no matter how complex the theory
gets in the rest of this particular
block the key step is always going to be
that when you have a continuously
differentiable function you can
essentially as long as you stay locally
you can essentially throw away the nasty
part you can essentially throw away this
error term because it goes to 0 so
rapidly that if you stay close enough to
the point X 0 y 0 no harm comes from
neglecting this term what you must be
careful about is that as soon as you
pick a large enough neighborhood so that
this term is no longer negligible then
even though this part here is still
Delta u sub 10 Delta u sub 10 is no
longer a good approximation for Delta u
any rate in n variables what we're
saying is suppose W is a function of x1
up to xn then if W happens to be
continuously differentiable at the point
corresponding to X bar equals a bar
meaning in terms of n topple
x1 up to xn is the point a1 , up to a n
then what we're saying is that Delta W
can be replaced by now this has been
mentioned in the text I don't remember
whether we've mentioned this in previous
lectures or not it's rather interesting
that when you deal with more than three
independent variables we somehow don't
like to use the word Delta W sub 10
because tangent indicates a tangent line
or a tangent plane which is a geometric
concept instead we replace the word line
tangent by Li n as an abbreviation for
Linea the key point being what that this
thing that we call Delta W sub Lin or if
you like to call it sub tan what's in a
name call it whatever you want the point
is that this thing that we call Delta W
sub Lin R Delta W sub tan is the partial
of F with respect to X 1 evaluated at a
bar times Delta X 1 plus etc the partial
of F with respect to X sub n evaluated
at a bar times Delta xn and the key
point is that once you have chosen a
specific number a bar notice that the
coefficients of Delta x1 up to Delta xn
are numbers they are not variables they
are numbers once a is chosen so that
what is Delta W Lin why do we call it
linear notice that this expression here
is a linear combination of Delta x1 up
to Delta xn in other words there what
sums of terms each involving a Delta X
times excuse me a Delta X times a
constant in other words again what we're
saying is that nice functions and what's
a nice function now a nice function is
one which is continuously differentiable
a nice function is locally linear in
other words that a continuously
differentiable function all right near a
particular point can be approximated by
a linear function where the error will
be very small as long as you stay near
the point in question now you remember
at the beginning of my life
I said something old something new this
finishes the old part of the course in
other words what I've tried to motivate
for you here is why if we were
remodeling the precalculus curriculum
much more emphasis should be paid to
linear equations granted that most
functions in real life are nonlinear the
point remains that locally functions are
linear okay that's the key point
locally we deal with linear functions
right therefore since all nonlinear
functions may be viewed as being linear
locally this motivates why we should
really study systems of linear equations
in other words this motivates the
subject called
linear systems now what is a linear
system essentially a linear system is M
equations in n unknowns in many cases M
and n are taken to be equal but what
kind of equations are they they are
equations where all the variables appear
separately to the first power multiply
the only by a constant term and by the
way let me introduce this double
subscript notation rather than
introducing umpteen different symbols
for constants notice that a very nice
device here is to pick one symbol like
an A and then use two subscripts the
first subscript telling you what row the
coefficient is referring to and the
second one which column are in terms of
the equations the first subscript tells
you which equation you're dealing with
and the second subscript tells you what
variable its multiplying for example
this is what this is the coefficient of
x sub 1 in the first equation this is
the coefficient of x sub n in the first
equation this is the coefficient of x
sub n in the empty Quay ssin etcetera in
other words think of this as the row and
the column if you will and what we're
saying then is that the solutions of
this type of system
equations are really controlled by the
coefficients of the X's in other words
by the nem the numbers a sub IJ where I
and J can take on well i takes on all
values from what the the number of rows
i goes from 1 to m and j goes from 1 to
n but the a's become very important and
this is what ultimately is going to
motivate what we mean by a matrix but
before I come to that let me give you
just one example of what I mean by
saying that the equations are governed
by the coefficients of the X's not by
the constants on the right hand side by
the way notice the convention that when
you have two equations with two unknowns
rather than call the unknowns x1 and x2
it's conventional to call the unknowns x
and y let's take a particularly simple
system here X plus y equals B 1 X minus
y equals B 2 if we add these two
equations we get 2x is B 1 plus B 2
whereupon X is B 1 plus B 2 over 2 if we
subtract the 2 equations we get 2y is B
1 minus B 2 whereupon Y is B 1 minus B 2
over 2
notice that this tells us how to solve
for x and y in terms of B 1 and B 2
namely to find X you take half the sum
of the two B's to find Y you take half
the difference now certainly the
solution depends on the values of B 1
and B 2 I'm not saying you don't change
the answers by changing the constants on
this side what I am saying is that the
structure by which you find the answers
does not depend on B 1 and B 2 it's
determined solely by the coefficients of
x and Y in other words what we're saying
is no matter what B 1 and B 2 are in
this particular problem to find x and y
we take half the sum of the B's and we
take half the difference in other words
the solution depends on B 1 and B 2 and
then numerically but not structurally
well the whole idea is this and this is
what we so often do in math
Malick's because the solution to our
equations depends on the coefficients of
the X's we somehow or other want to
focus our attention on the coefficients
and we don't need the X's in there
because we can sort of think of the X's
as being a place value type of situation
in other words x1 can be thought of as
being the first column X 2 the second
column the first equation can be thought
of as the first row the second equation
the second row and what this motivates
is a concept called an M by n matrix now
this sounds like a very ominous term an
M by n matrix but the point is it's not
a very ominous term it's in fact I think
that it's to that the word matrix
essentially mean indicates an array and
that's all this thing is by an M by n
matrix we simply mean a rectangular
array of numbers arranged to form M rows
in other words the first member tells
you the number of rows and the second
member tells you the number of columns
now there's certainly nothing logical
about that in terms of our game idea
just memorize this it's a rule of the
game or a definition somebody could have
said why didn't you give the columns
first and then the rows oh we could have
but one of them had to come first and
the convention is is that one refers to
the rows first and then the columns an M
by n matrix ten is what it's a
rectangular array of numbers consisting
of M rows and n columns by way of an
example let's and by the way to indicate
it you're talking about a matrix one
usually encloses the array in brackets
or in parentheses it doesn't make any
difference I will use whichever one
strikes my fancy at the moment and it
happens to be brackets right now but if
I write down this array what is it now 1
1 1 1 minus 1 2 this is a rectangular
array of numbers consisting of what 2
rows and 3 columns and so this isn't
sample of a 2 by 3 matrix a 2 by 3
matrix now again we don't want to invent
this thing vacuously let's keep track of
what this matrix is coding for us in
terms of a system of equations well for
example suppose we have the system of
equations e 1 is equal to y 1 plus y 2
plus y 3 Z 2 is equal to Y 1 minus y 2
plus 2 y 3 and we want to keep think of
the y1 y2 and y3 as being the variables
Z 1 and Z 2 sort of as being the
constants here what is the matrix of
coefficients here
well the matrix would be what the
coefficient of the first variable in the
in other words the first variable in the
first column is 1 second variable first
column is 1 third variable first first
row is 1 you see second equation first
variable coefficient is 1 second
equation right second variable
coefficient is minus 1 second equation
third variable coefficient is 2 so using
our matrix coding system the matrix of
coefficients would be what 1 1 1 next
row 1 minus 1 2 which is exactly the
matrix that we wrote down over here and
to put this into a different perspective
so to see what we're driving at let's
take a second example where we first
start out with three equations in four
unknowns three linear equations and four
unknowns and then we'll write the matrix
for this afterwards but let the
equations be Y sub 1 is X 1 plus 2 X 2
plus X 3 plus X 4 y 2 is 2 X 1 minus X 2
minus X 3 plus 3 X 4 y 3 is 3 X 1 plus X
2 plus 2 X 3 minus X 4 if I want to
write the matrix of coefficients what do
I do
I simply leave the variables out and
write down what my first row would be
what 1 2 1 1 my second row would be 2
minus 1 minus 1 3 my third row
would be three one two minus one in
other words my matrix of coefficients
now would be what kind of a matrix it
would be a rectangular array of numbers
consisting of three rows and four
columns alright and that would be called
a three by four matrix again notice in
this coding system the number of rows
corresponds to the number of equations
and a number of columns corresponds to
the number of variables that are formed
in linear combinations in other words to
summarize this again the matrix of
coefficients in our second example is
the 3 by 4 matrix 1 2 1 1 2 minus 1
minus 1 3 3 1 2 minus 1 well again let's
recall that when we do mathematics we
don't like to introduce notation for the
sake of notation and simply to be able
to have a way of conveniently writing
the coefficients but not being able to
use it efficiently would be a rather
stupid thing to do
there was why invent new notation if
it's not going to help us effectively
solve new problems this is why in
mathematics we've been emphasizing the
game idea whereby what we really care
about is structure we care about
structure not about the terms themselves
and to motivate what I'm driving at let
me return two examples one and two and
bring up a question that has great
impact and even if we don't appreciate
it right now in terms of a practical
application let's at least see what's
happening you notice that if I look at
these systems of equations over here
notice that the first two equations tell
me how to express Z 1 and Z 2 in terms
of y1 y2 and y3 on the other hand the
second system of equations tells me how
to express y1 y2 and y3 in terms of x1
x2 x3 and x4 now without belaboring the
point because the arithmetic is quite
trivial here
a very natural question that might come
up next is is look at let's look at our
old friend the chain rule again since
the Z's are expressed in terms of the
Y's and the Y's are expressed in terms
of the X's it seems that by direct
substitution I should be able to express
the Z's in terms of the X's namely I
replace y1 by this linear combination of
the X's I replace Y 2 by this linear
combination of the X's I replace Y 3 by
this linear combination of the X's I
then combine the Y's in terms of the X's
as indicated here and that should give
me the Z's in terms of the X's leaving
that hopefully as a trivial exercise we
come to the next example
what I'd like to mention here and that
is suppose we were told to express Z 1
and Z 2 in terms of X 1 X 2 X 3 and X 4
point is that with the amount of
arithmetic mentioned before we could
easily show that Z 1 was 6 X 1 plus 2 X
2 plus 2 X 3 plus 3 X 4 while Z 2 was 5
X 1 plus 5 X 2 plus 6 X 3 minus 4 X 4 by
a straightforward substitution the point
is that somehow or other we would like
to be able to handle this substitution
more efficiently in other words is there
a nicer way in either way of being able
to transform the Z's into the X's by way
of the Y's in other words is there a way
of replacing the Y's by the X's and then
finding Z's in terms of X's in a
convenient mechanical way that will save
us much steps not so much in these easy
examples where you have two by three and
three by four systems but cases where
you might have ten equations and ten
unknowns or ten equations and 12
unknowns and the answer is there is a
way and of course you knew there was
going to be a way otherwise we wouldn't
be leading up to it in this particular
way and as so often happens there
usually happens to be a real life
situation that motivates why we invent
something called something like matrix
algebra and the point is in terms of our
present illustration the chain rule that
we're just talking about expressing the
Z's in terms of the Y's and then the Y's
in terms of the X's motivates what we
mean by matrix multiplication and you
may notice that I put multiplication
here in quotation marks the reason I put
it in quotation marks is unfortunately
the word multiplication has a
connotation of multiplying numbers
together don't think of it that way
think of multiplication meaning what a
way of combining two matrices to form
another matrix there's going to be no
logic behind this other than one very
famous piece of logic that is that
knowing what the answer is supposed to
be we make up our rules to guarantee us
that we will get the appropriate answer
in other words I remember when I was a
undergraduate in college the big the big
type of humor that was going around at
that time was the idea if somebody would
give you the answer and you had to make
up the question oh they were silly
little things like if the answer to the
question was 9w what was the question
and the question would be do you spell
your last name with a V here vogner and
the answer would be 9w and these were
funny jokes at that time I don't know
where they're funny now or not but the
funny point is this that met this joke
which may not be that funny is exactly
how we motivate definitions and rules
and mathematics we start with the answer
and then go back and answer the question
knowing in advance that somehow or other
that the matrix that expresses the Z's
in terms of the Y's is given by this and
the matrix that expresses the Y's in
terms of the X's is given by this matrix
somehow or other what we would like to
do is invent a way of combining these
two matrices to give me the matrix that
expresses this answer in other words if
I start knowing what the answer is
supposed to be in other words what is
the matrix that expresses disease in
terms of the X's it's the matrix whose
first row is 6 to
two three and who second row is five
five six minus four in other words the
matrix would be what six two two three
five five six minus four and without
even looking at any mechanical rule the
question that comes up is how can I
invent a rule that will tell me how to
multiply this 2x3 matrix by this three
by four matrix to obtain this 2 by 4
matrix 2 by 4 matrix now look at in the
notes I'm going to do this in great
detail there will be many exercises on
this for you to sharpen your teeth on
but for now I just want to hit this main
point because the lecture is quite long
your attention span probably is starting
to be taxed and so I just want to show
you what the recipe is because my
feeling is that this is something you
have to hear before you can really read
it without becoming panicked by the
notation the idea is this first of all
to multiply two matrices all we ever
require is that the number of columns in
the first matrix equals the number of
rows in the second Matrix and if that
sounds complicated to you simply think
in terms of the chain rule again you see
the number of columns in the first
matrix tells you how many unknowns there
are in the first system of equations and
that number of unknowns is expressed
gives you the number of equations in the
second system in other words the number
of columns in the first matrix must
match the number of rows in the second
Matrix notice we don't get we don't care
about the number of rows and the first
one matching the number of columns in
the second all we care is that the
number of columns in the first matrix
namely three here
match the number of rows of the second
which is three then the rule works in a
very interesting mechanical way that
takes makes use of the dot product
namely what you do is suppose I want to
find the term in the product of these
two matrices
that occupies the second row second row
third column what I do is is I take the
second row in other words I take the row
comes from the first matrix I take the
column value from the second matrix in
other words I have what second row third
column and I form the usual dot product
that we've talked about in other words I
dot the second row with the third column
and what would I get if I did that 1
times 1 is 1 minus 1 times minus 1 is 1
and 2 times 2 is 4 so 1 plus 1 plus 4 is
6 so in this product matrix the term in
the second row third column will be 6
the term in the second row third column
will be 6 second row third column will
be 6 now leaving it as an exercise for
the time being and reading it in the
supplementary notes I'm sure you'll be
able to put this all together it's not
nearly as difficult as it sounds hearing
it the first time I think the most
difficult part is rationalizing why one
would invent such a definition in the
first place the answer is very simple we
invent the definition to solve a
particular problem in other words coming
back here again all I'm saying is that
if I invent for example let me just give
you one more checking out point here let
me see what the term would be in the
first row second column to find the term
in the first row second column I take
the first row of the first matrix dotted
with the second row of the second column
of the second Matrix see first row does
with second column the answer will give
me what the term and the product that's
in the first row second column let's
check that 1 times 2 is 2 1 times minus
1 is minus 1 1 times 1 is 1 2 minus 1
plus 1 is 2 and therefore the term in
the second first row second column
should be 2 and this you see there's no
more motivation to how we multiply these
two matrices than the fact that it
solves the problem that we want solved
in other words to find the term that's
in the ice row jth column of the product
dot the I throw of the first matrix with
the J's column of the second Matrix more
generally you can always multiply an M
by n matrix by an N by P matrix in other
words again what's the key factor you
don't care about the number of rows in
the first you don't care about the
number of columns in the second what you
do care about is what that the number of
columns in the first matrix be equal to
the number of rows in the second and if
you do that when you multiply an M by n
matrix by an N by P matrix notice that
the result will be what and M by P
matrix in other words the number of rows
is governed by the number of rows in the
first matrix and a number of columns is
governed by the number of columns in the
second Matrix notice by the way that
this tells us right away that when we
want to multiply two matrices it makes a
difference in which order that they're
written in other words if we were to
take that 2 by 3 matrix and the 3 by 4
matrix and interchange them we don't
have the appropriate match up of rows
and columns in other words you can't dot
a 2-tuple with a 4th tupple the very
fact that we say dot the row with the
column the dot product is only defined
for two n tuples we insist that the end
tuples be the same in other words the
end has to be the same 2.2 n tuples at
any rate let me summarize today's
lecture by saying that in overview
notice that we've done hopefully is that
we have reestablished the need for
linear systems of equations and secondly
once we have understood what the need
for linear systems is we are now
introducing a mechanism whereby we can
solve linear systems more efficiently
than what we were taught in the past as
to how to solve them you see what I'm
going to do for the next
lectures now is concentrate on a new
game called the game of matrix algebra
but that will unfold gradually as we
develop the next two lectures and so
until our next lecture so long
funding for the publication of this
video was provided by the Gabriella and
Paul Rosenbaum foundation
help ocw continue to provide free and
open access to MIT courses by making a
donation at ocw.mit.edu/donate